I have a notebook and I was nineteen
years old I was living in Ireland and we
got away Dublin where Cork South you
know it's my family's room and this I
was supposed to be paying attention in
school it wasn't I wasn't like a film
class and we usually had beers before it
anyway so but we would have there was
this girl from Maine I think she was
like another exchange student that we
were flirting what we'd do is we'd write
questions in a notebook and pass them
back and forth oh yeah I've been on a
band and so two years ago my wife and I
found it in my garage
and open it up and one of the questions
she had written me was what do you want
to be when you grow up
so I'm 19 and what I wrote was
essentially I don't know what the job is
called I do know it's gonna involve a
lot of being on the phone a lot of
yelling at people a lot of negotiation
high-risk high-reward and whatever it is
I'm gonna do it
halftime from the mountains halftime
from the beach into the end I'm gonna
wrap it up by the time I'm 40 and do
something else right so we don't 40th
birthday but we just had her for my 40th
I live it was quite a party yeah it was
it was a party I live up in the
mountains I live at the beach yeah and I
didn't even I'd never heard of the word
venture capitalist I didn't know what
this would they do and so this is
there's a new chapter coming and some
more stuff I'm working on so you you're
gonna do other things TV is one of those
things yeah I mean you enjoy it
I enjoyed it wasn't even like TV I
wouldn't like bucket at all like yeah we
guys in our position get offered shows
all the time sure but I think that show
specifically was super fun for me yeah
so a little more entertainment stuff
maybe probably a little bit and then
continuing to invest but a difference
just at things I that I'm just so
personally deeply convicted in in
venture company of ours run by Shivani
Sirois out of LA what do they do they if
you're in the developing world you
download their app they can immediately
tell by your phone how creditworthy you
are an instantly grant you a mobile
money loan in Kenya and Tanzania and the
repayment rates on those loans are above
90% like more than any folk alone in the
world so they're creating a middle-class
in in you know sub-saharan Africa with
technology being coded in Santa Monica
but it's like the most
gender diverse and culturally diverse
company I've ever worked with racially
diverse coming up ever worked with it's
super fun to go to work there and it's
gonna make a lot of money and yet we're
really proud of the impact it's having
and so that's something excited about I
actually serve on their board so there
will always be things I can't not look
away when I see something awesome that I
can help it's an addiction in that way
yeah but I you know I don't have any
plans now to raise money from people and
kind of continue building a lowercase
Empire